I'm giving you another fraction with
more certain that's okay
how would we rationalize this
denominator now so far if you saw
something like this you'd say there's a
root five the root five is the problem
so I'm just going to multiply by root 5
over 5 and it all just comes out Watch
and you've been doing that successfully
for the last a little bit but you run
into a problem and that's why I call
this someone challenging denominator if
you try it here because if you say root
2 is the problem and you just multiply
by root 2 over root 2 what happens
tell me what's right the nubrella it's
just one time YouTube which is Richard
and then on the denominator well these
guys work they become two but this also
gets multiplied by the 5 do you notice
that so then you like wait a second
by getting rid of this guy see that's
better
I've created this that's even worse than
it was right like I have drastically
made this a worser problem than when I
started
so this is no good it's not enough so
I'm gonna show you now you can pick up
your pens I'm gonna show you what will
rationalize this denominator and it's a
super useful skill it's a bit harder
than what you're being expected to do
now but I think you guys can manage it
if you stare with ok I'm still gonna
multiply by something over something
okay
but I'm gonna choose an unusual
something I'm not gonna explain why I
chose it just yet I'm gonna wait until
the end I wonder if you can work it out
with me watch instead about my roots
we're on route 2 I'm going to multiply
by the wrists no no that looks like a
bit of a mouthful that's okay stay with
me one step at a time
human me what does the numerator become
it's just one of these right so one of
these is just five minus root 2 is that
okay all right so far so good now when I
write the denominator I'm gonna write in
long form first it looks like this now I
know that looks that looks awful doesn't
it okay
but actually if you look carefully at it
watch what happens when I have you just
expense just watch okay um actually not
just watch do you write it with me but
see notice the numerator is just gonna
stay put if I start to expand this
denominator help me out five times five
five times minus root 2 minus 5 root 2 I
cast the first pit now I'm gonna do this
guy times that what's that look
plus 5 root 2 and in this one didn't we
get it all right four terms is it all
good I'm pretty happy with it
and do you notice what's happened right
here in the middle see that those two
guys are just gonna cancel out
like so okay they're just exactly
annihilating each other and I can just
say hey 25 and 2 are both rational and
I'm done so this is kind of neat we
start off with something what's very
strange like how are you deal with this
but if you're multiplied by the right
number then it does indeed rationalize
now the real question is how did I know
what number to multiply by can you see
how I chose it not randomly chose a very
specifically look at this number down
the bottom or rather this pair of
numbers now look at these guys can you
see how similar they are the numbers are
the same what's changed it's just that
sign in the middle right so this is
really important um in your working I'd
love you to have these as well if you
have another color or something like
that these two things here five plus
root 2 and 5 minus root 2 we call these
guys conjugates conjugates is a word
which just means they pair up they go
together they match in some useful way
and the useful way that they match up
with is like this do you see that when
you expand this these middle terms they
have to cancel out every time you can
make up any conjugates you like and
it'll happen let's just make one up here
4 plus root 3
what would the conjugate a describe it 4
minus root 3 now watch let's just do the
expansion right you're going to get 16
minus 4 and 3 plus 4 root 3 watch out
for the signs minus 3
do you agree and just like before look
this happens every time it happens okay
so if you choose conjugates then if
everything comes out in the wash you
don't get any speck just nice and by the
way just have a look at I need another
color just have a look at this
denominator over here 25 and 2 we're
back at the original fraction the very
first one I wrote on the board
25 and 2 what's their connection to
these two numbers it's just the squares
right you see that is really five
squared from here and this is root 2
squared does that make sense so in fact
if I saw something with something like
this I didn't even need to do all of
this expansion I know it's gonna do the
same thing every single time so let me
show you what it would look like if I
just skipped all of that unnecessary
working if I said to you hey can you
rationalize that you rationalize that
okay actually I will change it around
with it like that okay what is the
conjugate conjugate of that guy over
there all I do is throw the same numbers
with a plus sign okay the same numbers
with a plus sign
it's that okay if I do the top I'm gonna
do the bottom sorry
now notice remember just like before all
the surd bits are eventually just gonna
disappear they're gonna cancel with each
other okay so on the top I'll just leave
that guy there do you remember how I got
these two numbers it's just the squares
do you see that that's just the squares
so what's the square of this it's just
five what's the square of this
squares squares in this case
coincidently 5 minus 4 is just 1 so
therefore 3 on now and if you like if
you have bit suspicious you can go to
your calculator and you can punch in
this you'll give you a decimal of some
kind right I don't know what it is and
then go ahead and punch in this this is
the original question 3 on route 5 - to
go on it actually I'd love you to do it
right now
you've got a friend next to you I hope
he's got a calculator what have you put
in this and what do you put in that if
I've done my numbers right you should
find they are exactly the same does it
check out work out who's doing which
don't produce that 100 crazy the same
number but without this weird gross
rational denominator I can simplify it
so it's right here